the western intellectual tradition
suggests that in order to be happy what
we need to do most of all is to go out
and subdue the world secure resources
found businesses run governments gain
fame and conquer nations
by contrast the eastern tradition has
for a long while told us something very
different
in both its buddhist and hindu strands
it has insisted that contentment
requires us to learn to conquer not the
world but the instrument through which
we view this world namely our minds
it won't matter says the east how
lustrous and perfect our achievements
end up being how much money we
accumulate how many friends we acquire
so long as our minds remain open to
being troubled at any point by our
emotional faculties
all the benefits of a palace with seven
reflecting pools and gardens planted
with almond and cherry trees will be
wiped out by a depression chronic
anxiety will spoil the ownership of the
fastest jet
a fortune is of no use at all so long as
one is nagged by paranoia
an unhappy relationship at once destroys
any advantages of an esteemed name
given this vulnerability of external
goods to the vagaries of the mental
realm the eastern tradition advises us
to stop spending our time trying to
rearrange the material building blocks
of existence only then to fall foul of
psychological ills
and to focus instead on learning how to
control and manage the inherently unruly
and hugely complicated instrument
through which the external world reaches
consciousness
rather than striving to build empires we
need to spend many years examining how
we think and dream
we have to reflect on our families the
economic systems we were brought up
under the impact of our sexual urges and
the biological and cosmological order of
nature of which we are an infinitesimal
part
we have to learn how to breathe in such
a way as to allow maximal oxygen to
reach our frontal cortex and to hold our
bodies so that our organs are not
crushed and our blood flow subtly
impeded we need to be able to sleep a
regular number of hours and remove all
distractions and excitements that might
disturb our streams of thought
this is by no means an easy set of
priorities it is indeed as much hard
work as managing a law firm but the
yogis and sages advise that it delivers
us a far more secure hold on the actual
ingredients of contentment than the bank
account of a newly installed ceo with a
yacht of barbuda
some of the reason why this continues to
feel unreal is that we simply can't
imagine that success great wealth and a
palace wouldn't in the end do the trick
and that in turn is because too few
people who have been blessed with such
accoutrements have ever given us an
honest account of what it felt like to
have them
intellectual history with its dire
incantations against a worldly life has
been written by a set of suspiciously
poor and envious sounding people it is
therefore highly fortuitous and
extremely reassuring that buddhism
should have been founded by a
disgruntled former playboy siddhartha
gatama who once had a palace and a trust
fund fame and servants but gave them up
to sit under a bodhi tree and could
therefore tell us with the benefit of
lived experience what material goods can
really do and not do for us
and without false modesty he insisted
that they won't be enough
the food may be tasty and the room's
elegant but such advantages cannot serve
their purpose so long as one's mind is
haunted and unsteady as it invariably
will be without a long emotional
education and regular spiritual practice
we should take the east's warning
seriously however hard we strive it is
logical that we can only be as happy as
our minds are at peace
and given how vulnerable we are to
mental disturbances and how short our
lives are we should on balance almost
certainly spend a little more time on
our psyches and a little less time on
our plans for a second home and a new
york office
the west has produced too many unhappy
playboys and the east too many genuinely
peaceful sages for us not to shift our
attention away from conquering the world
towards taming our minds
for more from the school of life you can
subscribe to our channel and take a look
at our range of products on our website
you